ihm reicht es bayerns ministerpräsident
markus söder am nachmittag hat er den
corona katastrophenfall wieder
ausgerufen in seinem bundesland in
bayern da ist jetzt am lockdown so gar
nichts mehr leid ganz im gegenteil hatte
ausgangs beschränkung und der
schulunterricht findet in großen teilen
wieder von zu hause statt brauchen wir
einen solchen harten lockdown jetzt für
ganz deutschland weil die zahlen ja
einfach nicht runter gehen bundesweit
das ist die wichtigste frage die sie mir
geschickt haben an den kanzleramtschef
von angela merkel an helge brauchen
gerade ist davor gefahren hier um sich
der diskussion zu stellen dem politik
talk bei bild am sonntag abend jetzt
live herzlich willkommen mehr gebrauchen
bei uns im bild studio in regelmäßigen
abständen im wochenrhythmus oder
zumindest zwei wochen rhythmus
diskutieren wir darüber ob wir noch
härtere chor ohne regeln brauchen ist
ihr locker und einfach zu lasch gewesen
ja also schon bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am 14
oktober haben wir ja sehr intensiv um
die frage gerungen wie viel maßnahmen
müssen jetzt sein
und seitdem sehen wir eben die zahlen
gehen nicht richtig runter sondern wir
haben ein plateau erreichen das ist
nicht nichts sondern da haben wir schon
wirklich ja viele einschränkende
maßnahmen auch gemeinsam umsetzen müssen
aber dafür dass wir wieder unter 50
kommen muss einfach noch mehr passieren
aber ganz klar das war ja das ziel sie
wollten bin november also innerhalb
dieser vier wochen runterkommen auf die
50 wieder davon sind sie weit entfernt
gestartet sind sie mit ungefähr 126
incidents wert jetzt immer bei über 140
heute aktuell wieder incidents wert
bundesweit das heißt da ist es sogar
gestiegen wenn man sich das an cook ziel
ja komplett verfehlt
naja erstmal ist es ja nicht komplett
verfehlt wenn man von einem
exponentiellen wachstum auf dem plateau
kommt aber mehr weil auch immer wichtig
zu sagen
lange ein plateau halten ergibt noch gar
keinen sinn weil das können wir nur
durch dauer beschränkungen die am ende
sehr teuer sind und sicherlich auch
wieder von der bevölkerung schon gar
nicht von der davon betroffenen
wirtschaft
auch dauerhaft akzeptiert werden das
heißt jetzt muss man sagen wir müssen
weiter darüber diskutieren was wir noch
tun können
und da ist ja ein thema zum beispiel die
ganze zeit schon das thema schule
das will sehen dass die
ansteckungsfähigkeit bei den älteren
schülern ab der saison also dass es gibt
zwei schritte man kann einmal so ein
wechsel unterricht machen oder man kann
wirklich komplett distanz unterricht
machen das heißt die schüler gehen nach
hause und kriege quasi online
homeschooling und was befürworten sie
ich bin dafür dass man in den hotspots
die also wirklich jetzt weit weit
oberhalb des durchschnitts sollte
glücklich distanzen unterricht macht bei
den älteren
schauen wir mal an was bayern heute
beschlossen hat ich habs gerade schon
gesagt da gibt es wir harte harte
ausgangs beschränkungen ab jetzt in
bayern da hat der ministerpräsident den
ausnahmezustand ausgerufen am nachmittag
und so klang das wir müssen etwas tun
ich bin fest überzeugt davon kona lässt
einfach nicht locker
mir war auch nicht die zahl der
todesfälle zu reduzieren ist das gebot
der stunde
daheim bleiben kontakte reduzieren
kontakte vermeiden und versuchen keine
ansteckung weiterzuverbreiten tut jede
zahl nicht am tag hält der todesfälle
tut mir in das wirklich in der seele weh
wenn man sieht dass die alle eine
bisherige maßnahmen nicht ausreichen
dann wäre es eine moralisch nicht zu
vertretende ethisch nicht zu vertreten
behandlungsweise es einfach weiterlaufen
zu lassen und die zeit des schlupfloch
suche ist vorbei geht das also auch für
das bundesgebiet aus ihrer sicht ethisch
nicht mehr vertretbar moralisch nicht
mehr vertretbar das einfach laufen zu
lassen damit meinte auch sie es richtig
dass wir also ich bin auch weil ich der
meinung von markus söder wenn wir uns
das angucken von 100 todesfälle am tag
450 475 das ist nichts was man auf dauer
tolerieren kann und das hat die
bundeskanzlerin habe ich die ganze zeit
schon gesagt wir sind bereit mehr zu
machen
und natürlich sieht man jetzt in
deutschland dass die zahlen müssen
auseinander fallen im norden gibt es
schon zwei mal ganz ganz angucken
wir haben karten noch mal da da sehen
wir wie die ausgangssituation war anfang
november erster elfter da ist er locker
und in kraft getreten dann sehen wir
dass es sich erst tief rot einfärbt
eigentlich die ganze karte deutschland
zum risikogebiet ist und jetzt so in den
letzten tagen hat sich das ein bisschen
ausdifferenziert da gibt es dann im
norden im nordosten nordwesten er wieder
gelbe flecken und dagegen in der mitte
vor allen dingen auch weit im osten und
ganz im süden der republik wirtz knall
violett das ist die neue farbe hinter
dem rot sozusagen das heißt da ist es
noch schlimmer geworden
er ist richtig und deshalb muss man auch
differenziert rangehen also wenn in
mecklenburg-vorpommern oder
schleswig-holstein insolvenz von 50 auf
dies so ankommt wenn die schon
unterschritten ist kann ich da nicht
erwarten dass die noch sehr viel
zusätzliche maßnahmen machen aber
umgedreht alle die sich so schwer tun
überhaupt mit den zahlen runter zu
kommen sind jetzt auf dem plateau sind
oder die jetzt sogar noch stark steigen
die müssen deutliche zusätzliche
maßnahmen machen und wenn es
bereitschaft gibt dass wir das auf
bundesebene gemeinsam tun dann ist die
bundesregierung der vorne mit aber jetzt
für diesen impuls braucht es halt wieder
den söder sie hätten das jetzt nicht
geschafft noch mal anzuschieben und vor
weihnachten nochmals zu verschärfen
wir sind aus jeder
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am 14
oktober rausgegangen und haben gesagt
wir hätten uns mehr gewünscht und dann
aber immer eine diskussion ob man sich
in der schule überhaupt an steckt welche
wolle auch dass das treiben in den
einkaufsmeilen spielt ob das alles eine
rolle für infektions geschehen hat und
wir sehen jetzt das was an kontakten
momentan noch stattfindet das führt dazu
dass die infektionszahlen eben nicht
runtergehen das heißt wir müssen die
kontakte weiter beschränken und da muss
man natürlich auf das geschirr einkaufs
geschehen auf den bsv und auch auf die
schule gucken und aufhören zu sagen da
findet keine infektionsgeschehen ok sehr
söder macht jetzt nägel mit köpfen geht
voran treibt sie auch wieder treibt die
kanzlerin treibt den kanzleramtsminister
treibt die ministerpräsidenten-konferenz
gibt es da also diese woche noch mal
eine neue krisenrunde ich glaube wenn es
dabei den ländern eine breite
bereitschaft gibt sind würde also
auch dabei und die bundesregierung hat
die ganze zeit gesagt wir wollen mehr
machen
wir sind in jede konferenz reingegangen
mit der bereitschaft weitere maßen also
sie wünschen sich noch eine neue aber er
bleibt und deshalb wenn wir es schaffen
vor weihnachten einmütig noch gemeinsam
verschärfung erschließen sind wir dabei
ist ja schon erstaunlich also die
kanzlerin hat erst vergangenen mittwoch
sich im grunde in sachen
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz erst mal
über weihnachten hinweg gerettet und hat
gesagt also wenn es mich braucht dann
sind wir schon wieder da aber im grunde
sollte das erst mal so ausreichen so in
etwa übersetzt man dass man sich ja
gesagt natürlich sind wir schon da
grundsätzlich aber noch mal einen
ministerpräsidenten runde jetzt erst mal
nicht geplant werden am 25 november eine
runde gemacht und haben verschärfung
noch mal beschlossen
und da war es zum beispiel die krone
große wunsch der ministerpräsidenten
dass wir bei 200 einen neuen incidents
werden ein für und wir haben mehrfach
auch darüber diskutiert was bedeutet
dieser neue wert weil und mir war da
ehrlich gesagt mulmig bei welchem er
gesagt hat wir müssen runter auf 50 ich
weiß nicht welchen zusätzlichen wert ist
hat weitere instanzen jetzt im raum zu
stehen und alle haben gesagt das ist die
inzidenz ab dem der muss man ganz
besonders handel aber es gab nicht die
möglichkeit mal das genau zu hinterlegen
und zu sagen was machen wir denn dann
zusätzlich hat 200 und wenn wir das
schaffen würden jetzt stärker und mal zu
definieren und zu sagen überall wo die
inzidenz über 200 ist passiert auch
wirklich was nachvollziehbares
zusätzlichen dann wäre das garantiert
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wert jetzt
gehen wir es noch mal ganz kurz an sie
haben zu den schulen schon stellung
genommen da sind sie für distanzen
unterricht dort wo die hotspots eben
sind und sind insgesamt eher dafür eben
in diese
wechsel modelle überzugehen das betrifft
die schule was ist zum beispiel mit den
schulferien aber sagt söder früher in
die schulferien später raus auch ein
modell
wir hatten auch schon überlegt ob man
dann die schulferien etwas früher
beginnen lassen kann
aber das muss man eben sehen es wird
erst nach der wahl das ist das
allerdings ist das nur solange sinnvoll
wie wir sagen diese zusätzliche
ferienzeit und das haben wir den
herbstferien gesehen wenn die
alternative zu den zum schulunterricht
es ist dass man urlaub fährt dann wird
das infektionsgeschehen keine
verbesserungen ergeben sondern die
alternative muss möglich sein zu hause
zu bleiben und wenn wir das realisieren
können dann kann das eine sinnvolle
maßnahme seien aber im herbst werden wir
gesehen
da wurde nichts besser dadurch dass eine
schule zu war bei der herbst die leute
nicht den eindruck hat man schon sind
glaube ich die wenigsten die tatsächlich
sich nochmal ein weihnachts oder
winterurlaub vorgenommen haben eine
verlängerung der schulferien hat sich
also für möglich bundesweit
also ich finde nicht dass wir jetzt bei
den hohen infektionszahlen irgendwas
ausschließen sollten sondern müssen eben
wir in einer mpk nummer darüber
diskutieren wenn es nochmal bereitschaft
gibt was gemeinsam ist zu machen
ansonsten bleibt dabei haben wir auch
nach der letzten mpk gesagt dann müssen
diejenigen die hohe insolvenzen haben
eben auch von sich aus handeln also es
gibt nicht die möglichkeit zu sagen wenn
wir keine bundesweit einheitlichen
maßmann machen waren wir nicht sondern
das was also macht wenn schließt mit
deutschland halt die mitmacht oder meck
pomm dann machen wir es halt alleine sie
haben gerade busse und bahnen schon
angesprochen da können wir noch ein paar
bilder aus den vergangenen tagen
anschauen unter anderem aus frankfurt
aus den morgenstunden rushhour dort an
der u-bahn völlig überfüllte züge und
vor allem davor eben auch am bahnsteig
sieht so aus genauso in anderen städten
am wochenende habe ich auch erlebt in
berlin beim shopping natürlich egal ob
bruder im friedrichstraße die bahn alle
voll die leute kapieren dass natürlich
auch nicht mehr warum dort halt
der abstand nicht gewahrt wird warum man
den abstand da gar nicht waren kann und
dann bei weihnachten eben der
familienbesuch reguliert wird
also wir haben uns sehr viel mühe
gegeben ja auch bei der deutschen bahn
was zu machen haben wir jetzt dieses
verändert reservierungssystem ja es
gerade da wo man wirklich länger auch
vielleicht in einem umfeld sitzt das
dann nur jeder zweite platz reserviert
werden kann das finde ich sehr sehr
sinnvoll
man muss einfach sagen wir können auch
im öffentlichen personennahverkehr nicht
alles durch regulierung regeln sondern
jeder muss da auch selber ein bisschen
aufwand verwenden wir zur arbeit muss
das verstehe ich was wir da machen muss
er ja sagen und das schülerradio die
selbst schon am wochenende und so was
geht und ich glaube viele bilder sind
jetzt am wochenende entstanden wo die
leute dann hat wenn es einkäufe aber
frankfurt zum beispiel war mitten in der
woche bis dahin mittwoch da muss man
wirklich darauf achten dass man
alternative verkehrsmittel nutzt wo es
nur geht individuelle art ja vielleicht
auch fahrradfahren oder oder oder was
einem leben möglich ist aber eben wenn
man maske trägt wenn man nur kurz andere
leute trifft ist die ansteckungsgefahr
zwar geringer weil wenn das tausendfache
kontakte sind dann trifft ein paar eben
doch und dann werden infektionen weiter
getragen und deshalb ist sowas einfach
jetzt in dieser phase auch ein problem
und daran dass die sie sagen gerade
nichts ausschließen auch in der
weihnachtszeit noch möglich doch nochmal
beschränkungen zusätzlich im
einzelhandel zu machen geschäfte zu
schließen
also ich glaube darüber sollte man jetzt
nicht spekulieren mein eindruck ist dass
grundsätzlich wir gesagt haben wir
wollen jetzt dass du im
vorweihnachtsgeschäft die geschäfte
offen haben
damit das möglich ist und das jetzt
weiter zu verdichten ist wahrscheinlich
auch nicht klug aber wie man da
ansonsten mit verfährt glaube ich das
ist jetzt nichts was man was schon
spruchreif wird das war die häufigste
frage wir haben ja vorher aufgerufen
ihnen auch die drängendsten fragen zu
stellen da kamen wirklich eine flut
diesmal von fragen und unter anderem von
anne schimanski wie auch dieses thema
weicher oder härter locker und so
besonders
bewegt hat
also meine frage ist warum nicht endlich
konsequenter gehandelt wird
es ist doch nun sehr offensichtlich dass
dieser london lite absolut nichts bringt
und trotzdem wird immer noch um gefeiert
und sich daher zurück gehalten endlich
konsequenter zu sein und viele
entscheidungen getroffen die wir die
jetzt geschlossen haben müssen um ihre
existenz bank einfach nicht
nachvollziehen können warum werden zum
beispiel immer noch unzählige leute ins
ausland geflogen während hier die hotels
dicht haben und um ihre existenz bangen
verstehe ich nicht warum müssen betriebe
schließen die ein vernünftiges hygiene
konzept hatten sich auch daran gehalten
haben während in bussen und bahnen und
flugzeugen die leute immer noch dicht an
dicht sich drängeln und sitzen und
stehen und da überhaupt gar kein hygiene
konzept vorliegt wie sollen wir die
gerade um ihre existenz bangen das
verstehen
lieber einmal richtig als zehnmal
halbherzig und genau so läuft das aber
gerade halbherzig halbherzig gutes wort
also ich glaube in einem mal zu völlig
recht dass wir viele bereiche haben in
denen ein facharzt ende nicht gehalten
werden können ist ein problem deshalb
schon infektionszahlen so hoch dass uns
zu behaupten dass es irgendwelche orte
gebe wo es ansteckung grundsätzlich
nicht stattfinden
das ist sicher nicht haltbar sondern
ansteckungen finden überall der stadt wo
abstände nicht eingehalten werden können
und alltags massen reduzieren das risiko
wo sie heben müssen auch natürlich nicht
augen deshalb ist die aufgabe die wir
jetzt haben genau das klarer zu sein und
deshalb da wo wir abstände noch
ermöglichen können abstände und da wo
wird es nicht können die anzahl der
kontakte reduzieren das sind die zwei
maßnahmen die sind absolut notwendig und
umgedreht muss man denjenigen die jetzt
auch zum teil geschlossen haben die
sagen wir hatten in jene konzept wir
haben momentan in nahezu allen
lebensbereichen hygiene konzept aber
trotzdem wahr und hatten wir im
september schon und da sind die zahlen
im winter so exponentiell gestiegen
das heißt unsere hygiene konzepte waren
vielleicht ausreichend um uns durch den
sommer zu bringen aber sie waren sicher
nicht ausreichend um uns durch den
winter wobei viele wirte sagen jetzt
habt ihr die restaurants so gemacht die
bars zugemacht die kneipen zugemacht und
die zahl werden gar nicht besser zeigt
doch es lag nicht an den restaurants
bars und kneipen
doch die zahl dass wir haben ja mit dem
was wir beschlossen haben diese von
diesen freizeitbereich haben wir doch
gesehen dass von einem exponentiellen
wachsen und mit einer verdopplung zeit
von sieben tagen wo wenn man mal weiter
gerechnet hätte auf dem höhepunkt anfang
november dann wären wir im dezember
jetzt in katastrophalen zuständen
das haben wir schon mal geschafft durch
den teil der maßnahmen die wir jetzt
ergriffen haben zu vermeiden das ist
eine ganze menge vom exponentiellen
wachstum zu einer seitwärtsbewegung aber
es ist eben genau nur der halbe weg und
was das wichtigste daran ist dass wir
auch nicht vergessen dürfen viele
ansteckungen finden im privatbereich
statt das heißt es geht auch nicht ohne
die bürger und deshalb ist das glaube
ich das schwierigste an dem was wir
gerade haben dass wir fragen was hat der
staat erlaubt und das genau schöpfe ich
aus oder wenn er nicht genau hinguckt
dann handle ich auch von einer gewissen
diese diese nikolaus feiern wir heute
erlebt haben an verschiedenen stellen
das macht mich echt sprachlos weil es
ist total klar dass es eine
gesellschaftliche aufgabe ist und andere
länder auf der welt haben es uns gezeigt
wie man mit sehr sehr viel disziplin
durch die krise kommen her weil es sei
klare führung gab da wurde es halt
knallhart gesagt also beispiel
frankreich die haben sehr hohe zahlen
gehabt wie sie es viel besser wissen
knallharter locker und sagt die zahlen
runter belgien sowieso immer auf ganz
hohem niveau knallharter locker und
zeigt die kurve total runter das heißt
das haben sie im grunde verpasst ihm so
ein bisschen wischiwaschi gemacht und
jeder hat gedacht na gut und ist
vielleicht doch nicht so schlimm da kann
ich auch da meine eigenen regeln im
privaten machen und die sind sowieso
alle uneigentlich da und machen das alle
anders
wie sie es wollen dh da gab's halt viel
spielraum den sie gegeben haben naja
eigentlich nicht sondern wir haben auch
für den privaten raum mit den kontakt
beschränkungen immer sehr sehr klar
gesagt was geht und die tatsache dass
wir dann immer wieder so viele fälle
erlebt haben
die wo das nicht eingehalten wurde das
ist dass das ist schon ein ernstes
problem
wie viel es geht nicht um die tatsache
dass wir zu viel erlaubt haben sondern
es geht darum dass an zu vielen fällen
eben im privaten kontext das nicht
eingehalten wurde weil es vielleicht
auch nicht ernst genommen wurde und das
finde ich wirklich schlimm einmal für
diejenigen die jetzt unter dem
beschlossen sie haben super gemacht die
projekte hat super gemacht und die
bürger haben es versammelt nein ich habe
ihn ja vorhin schon gesagt ich war von
anfang an auch dafür dass wir in manchen
bereichen was schärfer beschränken
aber trotzdem muss man klar sagen wenn
wir ein freiheitliches land sind was in
den privaten bereich sehr sehr wenig
sozusagen mit kontrolle und mit vorgaben
hineinregnet und wenn im privaten
bereich ansteckung ein ganz zentrales
thema sind
das ist ganz offenkundig der fall ist
dann kommt es neben dem was wir im
öffentlichen raum schließen und
beschränken
ganz massiv auf unseren
gesellschaftlichen willen an diese panne
- bewältigen und man kann nicht immer
danach rufen dass der staat einen
kontrolliert sondern muss sagen ich bin
bereit in meinem privaten bereich auch
wirklich nicht mit zu wirken wenn das
wenn das dann alles klappt was halten
sie mit den erfahrungen der letzten
woche jetzt für wochen jetzt für
realistisch wenn sie auf der 50 sind sie
denn sein falls sie haben wir gerade
belgien und frankreich genannt wenn man
sehr konsequent beschränkt dann ist das
etwas was in der tat innerhalb von drei
wochen zu schaffen ist also wenn sie es
jetzt nicht also nächste woche setzten
sich dann noch mal zusammen
beziehungsweise schalten sich noch mal
zusammen angenommen dann finden sie
irgendwie eine einigkeit einigermaßen
zwischen den ländern in denen ländern
zumindest im süden gibt es knallharte
blog da und dann rechnet sie damit dann
können wir mitte januar auf der 50 sein
und auch dass der zeitplan ist das weiß
ich noch überhaupt nicht also
jetzt erst mal haben wir jetzt eine
situation wo am 25
november gesagt haben was machen wir
bundesweit
und dann sind die sind wir
auseinandergegangen haben gesagt darüber
hinaus handeln in den hotspots die
länder
wenn wir jetzt mal schauen gibt es
darüber hinaus eine bereitschaft
bundesweit auf gemeinsam noch dinge zu
vereinbaren und und wann ist das der
fall
das kann man jetzt noch nicht so sagen
stimmt es eigentlich noch das war ja der
wahrscheinlich meist gesagt satz in der
bundesregierung deutschland kommt so
super durch die krise stimmt doch
eigentlich gar nicht mehr oder
naja also so toll wie es im sommer war
ist es in der tat jetzt nicht mehr weil
die den wunsch ich habe am 14 oktober
weil dieser im bka gesetz als eine
historische chance wir sehen die zweite
welle kommt wenn wir die schnell brechen
und die zahlen wieder unten halten dann
haben wir es geschafft einer großen
infektionskrankheit quasi die die woche
21 hektar passieren konnte und das haben
wir nicht geschafft sondern wir die
zweite welle ist los gelaufen und wir
sind dann haben es dann geschafft besser
als andere
diese haben wir immer noch so frühzeitig
reagiert dass die zweite welle nicht so
einen hohen ausschlag hat wie in vielen
anderen ländern
aber die frage wie viele wie gut man
dann aber die zeit raus kommen hängt
davon ab ob wir die kraft haben jetzt
irgendwann zu sagen wir gehen ganz
konsequent wieder runter unter die 50
weil das muss man sich ja immer sagen
warum das ist ja kein selbstzweck wir
wollen unter die 50 erstens weil dann
weniger menschen sterben weil man die
die nachverfolgung von über die
nachforderungen bei gesundheitsämtern
hier funktioniert was auch heißt wir
müssen viel weniger beschränken um dann
noch eine seitwärtsbewegung in herten
regen wir machen die runde einmal ein
bisschen größer und holen philipp rösler
dazu früher vizekanzler dann
ja unter anderem resultats minister
wirtschaftsminister lebt jetzt im moment
in der schweiz herzlich willkommen
schönen guten abend herr rösler haben
darüber gesprochen ob das noch so
richtig ist dass deutschland das richtig
gut macht sie haben ja verschiedene
blickwinkel noch leben in der schweiz
wie gesagt und sie waren jetzt gerade
kürzlich wieder dort wo ihre wurzeln her
kommen sozusagen in vietnam und das ist
ganz erstaunlich wie die entwicklung
dort ist was haben sie da gesehen wie
man mit der krise umgeht in vietnam herr
rösler
aber in der tat sind die zahlen wir
können alle sehr gut glück man hat nur
57 todesfälle zu beklagen aufgrund von
corona und auf 790 millionen einwohner
auch nur insgesamt 1700 fälle also
selbst wenn man gewisse dunkelziffer da
mit einrechnet sind die zahlen dort nach
wie vor weltweit etwa gleich sehr sehr
gut
ich glaube man hat zu anfang sehr hart
reagiert wie übrigens viele asiatischen
staaten und hat sofort die grenze dicht
gemacht und herz wenn du ein einziger
fall irgendwo aufgetaucht ist ganze
regionen quasi mit einem lockdown belegt
das hat dazu geführt dass man die erste
welle gut beherrschen konnte und als man
dann im sommer aus ein bisschen
gelockert hat und dann auch wieder erste
fälle aufgetreten sind gab einen fall in
einer touristengegend einen einzigen
fall darf man dann gleich 70 tausend
touristen ausgewiesen um sozusagen
gleich von vornherein des virus
einzudämmen
das hat dann gewirkt so dass man jetzt
im land selber sehr viele
freizügigkeiten hat aber nach wie vor zu
dem preis dass von außen eigentlich
fasten mit rein darf sich als ganz ganz
wenige ausnahmen und dann auch nur unter
wirklich was sie in quarantäne maßnahmen
wir sind gerade noch mal ein paar bilder
herr rösler von ihrem besuch dort sie
sind dort auch unter anderem in den
abend fernsehen nachrichten gelaufen
vielleicht können wir das noch mal ganz
kurz sehen das war ihr besuch in dieser
woche wie gesagt
in dem vorzeige lanckorona vorzeigeland
so sag ich mal vietnams sie waren dort
auf einladung des premierministers in
vietnam und da sehen wir sie noch mal
die lage tatsächlich so herr braun
der gab es auf dem höhepunkten incidents
wert von 50 das heißt das war die
absolut schlimmste lage in vietnam und
mittlerweile sind die auf null runter im
winter und die sind ja ungefähr von der
einwohnerzahl vergleichbar mit
deutschland da kommt er nicht mal im
ansatz behaupten dass wir das gut im
griff haben
also es gibt ein paar unterschiede und
in der tat ich mein ich freue mich ja
und das war immer mein erklärtes ziel
das auch wieder so ein land sind und
deshalb bin ich jetzt dafür dass wir
nachdrücklicher handeln aber es gibt
natürlich ein paar dinge die in die
machen das bei uns in europa besonders
schweres eine ist wir sind ein land
mitten in europa man sieht also süd
korea halbinsel lage japan insellage das
sind länder die kommen sehr gut durch
die krise und wir hatten ja von anfang
an mit grenzschließung grenzkontrollen
grenzpendlern unglaublich viele
herausforderungen und man sieht auch
jetzt tschechien war in einer sehr
schwierigen situation hat das jetzt
gedreht aber die konsequenz ist auch da
wo wir in bayern oder sachsen an
tschechien an grenzen hat das auch so
sehr hohen fallzahlen mitgeführt also
chef man hat uns die nach unten wenn man
so eine lage mitten in europa hat und
auf die arbeitskräfte in den
grenzregionen auch angewiesen ist also
sich so nicht abschotten kann wie
philipp rösler das gerade erzählt hat
weil man eine unglaublich verwobene
volkswirtschaft hat dann ist es
natürlich sehr sehr schwer quasi eine
strategie zu haben dass wir uns komplett
aus dem land zu halten und deshalb muss
man es im land gut kontrollieren größer
da sie ja selber auch
gesundheitsminister waren in früheren
zeiten wie geht ja ihre einschätzung
jetzt sind die zahlen halt schon so hoch
hat man den zeitpunkt ihrer meinung nach
verpasst wo es noch möglich war die
zahlen halt relativ schnell konsequent
runter zu kriegen
wenn wir da natürlich auch noch mal
wählen deutschland der anfang sehr sehr
gut gemacht also dass davon hinter
schätzen für sein großes land und über
hollands gerade gesagt in der mitte
europas ist in der tat eine andere auch
geografische herausforderung ist es gut
gelaufen im sommer glaube ich hat man
vielleicht versucht daran zu denken dass
im herbst nochmal eine ähnliche lage
aufträgen kann vielleicht da etwas
zuviel gelockert so dass dann schon so
viele infektionen in deutschland selber
lande gewesen sind dass jegliche
maßnahmen mit dann extrem schwierig wird
viele sagen ja man hat dann die zweite
welle nicht gesehen das glaube ich nicht
man habe im prinzip zu spät und zu wenig
darauf reagiert mit ist auf die zweite
welle
obwohl man ja gesehen hat dass mit den
richtigen harten auch starken maßnahmen
in der ersten welt man durchaus auch
folge haben kann aber ich mache dieses
zu spät
aber ich glaube das ist so
fertigen sie noch nach in eine wunderbar
das ist meine jetzige analyse zu sagen
im sommer hat immer schlechter tipp mehr
machen müssen um die situation jetzt
etwas besser zu haben zu können
über die widersprüchlichkeit auch von
der einen oder anderen corinna regel
gesprochen schauen wir noch mal rein wir
haben die bilder vom bahnsteig bei uns
gesehen ähnliche bilder aus dem ausland
spektakulär geradezu in london vom
herbst sah das gestern so aus tausende
menschen dort dicht dicht dicht gedrängt
und erstaunlicherweise dort anders als
hier in den großstädten alle ohne maske
das sind schon spektakuläre bilder
brauchen ein crooner zeiten ja abstand
und maske sind nun mal das a und o in
diesen zeiten und muss man einfach sagen
wenn man in so eine situation kommt dass
man sieht hier ist mit abstand nicht zu
haben
man muss man seine pläne halt eben auch
wieder ändern und dann verschiebt man
seinen einkauf oder was auch immer
aber irgendwie diese hoffnung die manche
haben sich ändern meinen plan nicht und
schon heute wird nichts passieren
dieser plan geht jeden tag in
deutschland 22.000 mal schief das macht
die leute halt wütend natürlich werden
noch zwei weitere fragen bekommen eine
kommt von andreas bruder dazu
warum müssen alle restaurants
geschlossen bleiben und in bus und zug
und so weiter ist man ohne jeglichen
minister abstand einer ansteckung
ausgesetzt
warum
kumpels ein bier trinken aber mit 700
wildfremden am bahnsteig stehen wo ist
da die logik er wo ist da die logik herr
braun
also man kann nicht alle dinge exakt
gleich behandeln weil ansonsten würden
die menschen im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr wirklich nicht mehr
zur arbeit kommen können weil man kann
vielleicht einen zusätzlichen bus fahren
lassen aber wir können zum beispiel
nicht in den großstädten die u-bahn
verdoppeln das geht einfach nicht und
deshalb ist ganz klar dass in einer
mischung aus lüften maske und der allen
versuchen durch home office und anderes
auch für ein bisschen ausdünnung der der
der des des des traffics in den
persönlichen personennahverkehr zu
sorgen das alles soll dazu beitragen
auch dort die infektionsrisiken zum
reduzieren und angesichts der tatsache
dass die zahlen jetzt so hoch sind finde
ich auch noch mehr zu reduzieren aber
das sind eben bereiche wo man sagen kann
wenn man wenn man sie schließen würde
kämen die menschen nicht mehr zur arbeit
das funktioniert auch nicht ganz das
heißt es gibt gewisse kompromissbereit
kann man eine ansteckung nicht zu 100
prozent ausschließen
und das war ja auch die logik warum wir
gesagt haben wir schließen den
freizeitbereich weil der 1 1 n in all
diesen prioritäten natürlich leichter
verzichtbar ist der weg zur arbeit das
sind einfach abwägung und die kommt man
in so einer pandemie nicht druck wieder
an teilweise eben die ganze logik
irgendwie auszuhebeln scheinen
naja so aufbrechen behandlung schauen
und sagen es muss alles exakt gleich
behandelt sei nur weil die einen halt
ganz streng sind zum beispiel wenn es
ums weihnachtsfest geht das dann viele
ganz ganz konsequent sich an die regeln
halten und überlegen ob tante erna eben
noch kommt oder dieses jahr mal nicht
oder auch die oma eben schon nicht unter
gleichzeitig sieht man eben diese bilder
direkt vor der haustür bei der s-bahn
machen die runde nochmal ein bisschen
weiter und holen
uwe hück dazu der aus der spd gerade
frisch ausgetreten ist und der sich auch
mit der korona logik natürlich
beschäftigt wir haben diese bilder der
hübschen guten abend gerade gesehen von
den bahnsteigen aus den vollen bahn eher
braun erklärt ist ja warum das dazu
kommt und sieht irgendwie auch die
mittel begrenzt man kann halt nicht noch
tausende u bahn zusätzlich plötzlich her
holen und so weiter irgendwie müssen die
leute zahlen zur mit der bahn ja auch
zur arbeit kommen wie würden sie das
lösen gibt es da eine lösung also erst
mal ich würde gerne ganz vorne anfangen
wir hatten die erste phase gut
gemeistert
die politiker haben vergessen dass erwin
dass er krank ist und im sommer haben
sie sich keine gedanken gemacht wie
bereiten wir uns vor aufgezeigt
das ist eigentlich der eigentlichen
probleme haben denn wenn ein haus brennt
ist die frage wer als erstes ja und da
sage ich ganz offen wie die doppelmoral
der politiker das ist das was den
menschen wirklich auf den geist geht
einerseits dürfen wir nicht mehr als
fünf leute privat sein aber die parteien
machen hat kein treffen mit 609 200 400
leute das kapieren die menschen nicht
auch die gastronomie ja wirklich eine
einzigartige konzept gehabt als auch
außerhalb ihrer gas- sowie die leute
eigentlich auch zu befliegen das ist das
was den menschen ganz nach löws und
erfahrungen ich habe zugehört und ich
schätze sie als menschen sehr arg aber
ihre ausführungen konnte ich und viele
andere menschen mit sicherheit nicht
nachvollziehen weil sie nicht
konsequenzen ihrer eigner
ihre hits zum beispiel nun sie unter
anderem die man mit dem
bundespräsidenten und präsidenten etwas
beschließen ohne die bundesparlament
einzubeziehen da schon an dass die
menschen sagen wie beim menschen machen
unsere politik unsere demokratien
da sage ich einfach wie sie die menschen
nicht ein beziehen sie menschen nicht
überzeugen wenn sie die menschen nicht
erreichen könnte 100 x 100 x kann damit
ihre bundespräsidentin und präsidenten
gamen klären
sie werden das mithin griechen unser
motto ist ziehen sie die menschen ein
und machen sie nicht dass oder gegen sie
uns nicht das gefühl dass wir nicht
intelligent genug sind zu wissen was man
zu machen habe ich dir vollkommen recht
masken ist pflicht außerdem eine orgel
die bundesregierung sagt kasten macht
kurz ja etwas der reihe nach durch dann
gehen was der reihe nach durch der erste
vorwurf der doppelmoral so kommt
zumindest ja bei vielen leuten an das
ist halt das absurde sie beschließen das
natürlich haben auch gute argumente dazu
und dann wird sich hier und da nicht an
die regeln gehalten und da gibt es
solche bilder den u-bahn- und dass
dieser wird ja alle regeln dann wieder
nur denkt man da muss ich mich auch
nicht mehr daran halten
na ja also ich glaube dass wir sehr
deutlich gemacht haben als
bundesregierung was wir uns wünschen
wir kämpfen für diesen incidence wert
von 50 wir kämpfen dafür dass die zahlen
runter gehen und darüber für haben wir
übrigens auch den ganzen sommer schon
gekämpft weil gerade sagt ihr habt euch
nicht vorbereitet wir haben unglaublich
daran für gekämpft dass die
gesundheitsämter aufgerüstet werden wir
haben von wenigen hunderttausend auf
millionen tests für uns vorbereitet wir
haben wir haben schutzausrüstung gekauft
wir haben zusätzliche intensivbetten
dass wir haben uns vor dem brand hatten
sie nicht in der tasche was passiert
wenn die zahlen wieder rasant steigen
dann mussten sie immer wieder ad hoc
entscheiden immer wieder nach steuern
jede woche sich aufs neue treffen immer
wieder verschärfen naja aber wir haben
im sommer ganz klar gesagt um einen
bundesweiten lockdown zu verhindern muss
jeder hotspot konsequent handeln und
kriegt alle hilfe von bundes und landes
das war das ziel und dann im sommer hat
das lange zeit funktioniert bis in den
september
und als wir dann
tagt am 14 oktober jetzt müssen wir
handeln weil jetzt merken wir in immer
mehr bereichen dass wir eben die kontakt
nachverfolgung aus der kontrolle kriegen
jetzt ist der punkt gekommen wo es eben
nicht mehr reicht lokal zu handeln
müssen etwas gemeinsam tun
da haben wir angefangen sozusagen darum
zu bringen dass wir genug tun und der
bund hat jedes mal mehr vorgeschlagen
ist das was wir am ende gemacht haben
erhöht nach einer kurz widersprochen
dann springen wir einen schritt weiter
sommer vieles getan
schön dass sie da widersprechen die
gesundheitsämter sind nicht einheitlich
ausgestattet das bedeutet meistens
täglich arbeiten also das was noch vor
30 jahren um eine u-bahn immerhin
geschlecht also da war ich aber und da
sind wir einmal miserabel
es sind digital mäßig in die
gesundheitsämter in allgemeine ämter
wieder aufgestellt nennt sie das iphone
zur kenntnis dass wissen die bürger und
solange sie das abschneiden dann führt
hatten wir uns etwas das man sagen
neben uns nicht für die fallzahlen
melden wir inzwischen voll digital muss
man sagen und das war in der tat im märz
april noch nicht so wir haben sofort
hilfe für jedes gesundheitsamt zur
digitalisierung gegeben und gestecken
jetzt über die nächste zeit noch weitere
milliardensummen in die modernisierung
der gesundheitsämter also und das
wichtigste bei der kontakt nach
verfolgung ist das personal und da wo
anfang des jahres eigentlich nur drei
vier leute waren die das konnten und die
dafür auch zeit hatten haben wir jetzt
in vielen gesundheitsämtern hunderten
von leute und übrigens auch 15.000
soldaten
kein mensch braucht das genannt hat
seine vorhersage ich mal flapsig vorher
waren dafür andere dinge jedenfalls
zumindest spielt und das immer in unser
aller alltag selten ist eine große rolle
und das hat sie natürlich samt gewandelt
ein schritt weiter einmal erinnert dass
eine große thema war unsere zuschauer
wie entwickelt sich jetzt natürlich
entwickelt sich die krone regeln und
ganz ganz viele haben gefordert menschen
müssen verschärfen wir kommen ja nicht
runter das sehen wir alle
und dadurch wird länger und länger und
länger das war das eine thema das andere
große thema war impfung und viele ärgert
sich darüber dass die briten
ausgerechnet die briten die brekzie
briten schneller sind wie finden sie das
dass die uns zu fühlen dass manche jetzt
auch noch den impfstoff wegnehmen ich
glaube deutschland ist da wirklich auf
gutem wege sich die impfdosen zu sichern
für die eigene bevölkerung bereitet
jetzt ja auch schon vor dass möglichst
schnell und flächendeckend geimpft
werden können ich meine es eine enorme
logistische aufwand sondern glaube ich
sind wir gut aufgestellt wir brauchen
würde ich neidisch auf andere staaten zu
gucken gegenteil ich wenn ich das in
änderungen haben die anderen staaten
gerade großbritannien auch auf
deutschland weil ich gesehen habe dass
man von außen man sich mal die apps und
ähnliche dinge ansieht also ich glaube
da ist man gut aufgestellt und jetzt
hoffe ich nur dass der impfstoff bald
kommen zugelassen wird wirkt und dass
die impfung dann auch schnell vonstatten
gehen können ist doch komisch herr braun
dass die briten das so schnell an den
start bringen können und wir eben nicht
bei uns dauert bei uns mal noch die
mühlen der bürokratie
nein wir uns mal nicht die mühlen der
bürokratie sondern wir haben eine ganz
klare entscheidung getroffen dass wir
eine ein ordentliches
zulassungsverfahren keine ad hoc notfall
zulassung das könnten wir auch aber wir
haben uns entschieden wir machen das
nicht sondern wir wollen dass die
vollständigen unterlagen über die
studien eingereicht werden dass die
stiko die dafür zuständig ist und das
paul-ehrlich-institut sich das angucken
die werden das in wenigen tagen tun
werden die unterlagen alle da sind
und dann werden auch wir innerhalb von
wenigen wochen tagen eine zulassung für
den impfstoff erteilen wenn es
verantwortbar ist aber wir machen eben
keinen abstrich wir halten das nicht für
verantwortbar sie finden den britischen
weg nicht verantwortungsvoll
das muss jedes land selber entscheiden
das sei die logische sie standen ja
genau vor der wahl sie hätten es machen
das heißt das was die briten waren
finden sie nicht fad wir haben uns gegen
einen akuten notfall zulassungen
entschieden auf diesen daten stand
sondern wir wollen eine zulassung nach
vorlage aller unterlagen aber was ist da
eine selbst entschuldigung ist das
leichtsinnig also wenn man das jetzt
gemacht hätte dann geht man höre
risiko an das wäre leichtsinnig den
bürgern gegenüber
nein ich finde das und das habe ich über
die jahre auch als mediziner immer
gemerkt das thema impfen ist ein sehr
sensibles und bei früheren fällen wie
auch bei der schweinegrippe zum beispiel
haben wir gesehen dass das vertrauen in
einen impfstoff von aller allergrößter
bedeutung ist dafür dass die menschen
auch bereit sind sich impfen zu lassen
und deshalb finde ich zu sagen bei uns
entscheiden das unabhängige behörden die
in einem nicht notfallmässig abgekürzten
verfahren und nach vorlage aller
unterlagen eine zulassung erteilen und
dann kann man diesen impfstoff auch
entsprechend vertrauen das ist eine ganz
wichtige basis weil wir werden am anfang
nicht genügend impfstoff für alle haben
aber irgendwann wird der punkt kommen wo
wir auch darum werben müssen dass noch
mehr leute sich impfen lassen
und dann ist ein sehr sehr sehr klares
zulassungsverfahren nach unseren
europäischen regeln aus meiner sicht ein
großer wie eine andere grund warum es
länger mit der zulassung dauert könnte
ja herr hück sein dass wir noch gar
nicht fertig sind mit der verteilung
dass wir es gar nicht hinbekommen hätten
werde die zulassung schon da und wir
wussten gar nicht mehr wie wir den
ganzen kram verteilen sollen oder haben
sie beispielsweise in pforzheim den
eindruck dass das super klappen wird mit
der impfstoff verteilung dass man
sorgfältig damit umgehen sollen an dass
die menschen nicht ausgesucht garantien
bewenden browns haben sie doch ganz
einfach ist das nun ändern waren das
werden wir in deutschland nicht
bahnfahren wird ist nicht in ordnung
finden politiker wissen auf dem kopf und
nicht roma entschuldigung dass ich jetzt
sage aber jetzt auf ihre frage im ort
seien ja ich bin überzeugt dass sein
hund ausgestattet ist dass wir schnell
und zügig und ordentlich impfen können
wenn wir ein impfmittel haben aber da
möchte ich dann schon zu sein gestehen
wir müssen sorgfältig damit umgehen
wir können nicht zulassen dass die
menschen nur bei einer schneller sein
möchte in russland dann zur leidenschaft
gezogen wir wir müssen sorgfältig sein
wir müssen die menschen anständig und
auch vorausschauend bahn jetzt haben
denn um denselben impfstoff am ende aber
ein haken dran sie finden das alle
vernünftig haben sie denn konkretes
datum im kopf verbrauch wo sie sagen
okay dann wird bloß geimpft in
deutschland das wird der tag sein
vorige woche seien also das hängt jetzt
natürlich von diesen unabhängigen
gremien ab aber ich rechne damit dass
das ganz früh im nächsten jahr in den
aller ersten tagen losgehen kann
und am anfang wird es auch noch gar
nicht so kompliziert sein weil er
vermutlich erstmal auf das
gesundheitswesen leute die direkt mit
patienten zu tun haben und so geimpft
werden sollen
dafür müssen alle anderen noch einen
moment zurück stehen richtig logistisch
aufwendiger und spannend wird es wenn
wir hoffentlich im frühsommer so viel
impfstoff haben dass wir wirklich breite
teile der bevölkerung impfen können und
dann wird es eine logistische
herausforderung
da müssen alle mithelfen aber ich kann
nur sagen wenn ich mal sozusagen in
meinem studien und freundeskreis der
ärzte um höhere eigentlich fast alle
sind bereit auch daran mitzuhelfen dass
wir dann wenn es drauf ankommt schnell
viele leute im funk das selber alle
durch impfen würden sie mitmachen sie
sind ja mediziner ich bin auch bereit
mitzumachen das geht dann nicht zu jeder
tages und nachtzeit war als
kanzleramtsminister aber am wochenende
bin ich bereit mitzumachen als
interessant und dann an ihrer uni klinik
oder privat einfach da kommt man ins
kanzleramt kann sich für ihn impfen
ich bin genauso wie alle anderen
kollegen über die landesärztekammer
hessen angeschrieben worden
oder wo die bereitschaft abgefragt wird
und mein bogen geht im nächsten tagen
zurück mit der bereitschaft an den
wochenenden auch mit das interessant und
sie können es auch noch da bin ich sehr
und ich das dass das zusätzliche risiko
wird bei ihnen herr größter sind ja auch
arzt sie sind auch mediziner schließen
sich an
sie sitzen der schweiz ist für uns ein
bisschen blöd aber ich habe schon den
ersten teil habe ich mitgeholfen an
meiner alten hochschule in hannover ein
behelfskrankenhaus mit aufzubauen mit
der bundeswehr gemeinsam auf dem
messegelände auf geradem andere bei uns
ging es dann um die frage auf der
position und andere themen
übrigens ist das bis ende dezember noch
gesichert war wie gesagt dann vielleicht
kommt ja noch mal eine zweite welle aber
klar
dann hätte ich gerne mit und hände
gebrauchen
bei ihm möchte ich nicht dass sie mich
kennen sie noch als kickboxer das
überlassen sie den beiden wird sich frau
merkel von ihnen impfen lassen das wäre
ja ein praktisches textor einfach zeigt
die spitze von kanzleramtschef wird sich
dann selbst entscheiden wird sich
öffentlich machen eigentlich joe biden
hat ja genau das angekündigt also ich
glaube wir werden uns impfen lassen das
gilt für die kanzel und das gilt auch
für mich
und zwar dann wenn wir dran sind ich
habe ja gesagt erst mal kommt jetzt
gesundheit und daran öffentlich das ist
ja eine enorme wirkung das ist ja
verfängt java scheint mehr als jede
impfkampagne wenn sich die kanzlerin
hinsetzt und öffentlich impfen lässt
also ich glaube dass man sich impfen
lässt das ist erstmal die entscheidende
botschaft um auch zu sagen wir vertrauen
unseren impfstoff und dem
zulassungsverfahren was ja dahinter
steht auch wenn jetzt auch noch und da
davon ein foto veröffentlicht mit einer
spritze im arm das muss ich dann jeder
aber auch wirklich alles da
sie haben gerade schon gesagt wie sehr
das emotionalisiert oder wie sie
sensibel dieses thema ist das merkmal an
unseren zu schritten zb von christian
müller
wenn ich gegen korona geimpft bin muss
ich dann im supermarkt beim einkaufen
immer noch eine schutzmaske tragen ja
muss er oder was er nicht
also wird es zwei fahren gehen das erste
ist wenn wir jedem in deutschland das
angebot gemacht haben dass unseren
impfen lassen kann
dann hätten wir sowieso alle
beschränkungen auch dann gibt es keinen
grund mehr dafür
wer sich dann noch nicht hat eben
darüber reden jetzt das dauert monate
bist du ja aber ich hoffe dass wir
irgendwann im laufe dieses jahres in
einen solchen zustand kommen und dann
muss derjenige der sich nicht impfen
lässt sein infektionsrisiko selber
tragen
in der phase davor wo wir noch nicht
genügend impfstoff haben sagen wir ja
dass zb menschen im gesundheitswesen
arbeiten vielleicht polizisten
vielleicht wäre also bestimmte gruppen
zuerst den impfstoff bekommen die das
ist ein vorteil dessen und wir anderen
stehen alle zurück weil wir es richtig
finden dass diese gruppen wegen ihrer
besonderen gefährdung zuerst geimpft
werden
dann heisst das aber umgedreht dass ich
nicht richtig finde wenn diese gruppen
dann daraus weitere vorteile ziehen das
heißt sie sind erst mal egal ob geimpft
oder nicht geben für gifte gibt es keine
zusätzliche freiheit herr rösler aus
erinnerungen an ihre partei der freiheit
ist das gerechtfertigt wir können ja mal
andersherum fragen wenn jemand sowieso
schon in den vergangenen monaten ja auch
immer eingriffe in die freiheitsrechte
erlebt hat beispielsweise als gastronom
und der sagt okay jetzt bin ich geimpft
und ich mache meine kneipe oder mein
restaurant auf ausdrücklich für geimpfte
können sie es ihm dann noch verbieten
oder kann der herr braun ihm zu einem
noch verbieten partei der freiheit
freiheit gibt es nie ohne verantwortung
und es gibt aus meiner sicht vor allem
zwei gründe sich impfen zu lassen
erstens um sich selber zu schützen und
zwar eins um andere zu schützen
diese beiden gründe alleine reicht aus
um impfen zu gehen da brauche ich nicht
noch andere in anführungsstriche anreize
weil ich dann irgendwie ohne maske
dagegen kann oder
das lenkt den fokus glaube ich auch in
eine falsche richtung wichtig ist dass
impfen noch mal um sich und andere zu
schützen
sehen sie das so also die leute mit
denen sie sprechen wenn die irgendwann
geimpft sind kapieren die noch warum
verdient dieselben regeln gelten sollen
masken pflicht quarantäne regeln
abstandsregeln keine feiern
privat kontakt verboten und so weiter
werden die das kapieren wie sich heute
in gastronomie ist nicht verstehen die
ja im ganzen insolvenz hin was müssen
sie einmal wissen großkonzernen geholfen
wenn ich die luft fangen so sehen und
hier werden sehr sehr viele kassen
wichtig stärker bertlich insolvenzen
finden sind sollen dann auch das recht
haben das sind dann die gastronomie
wieder öffnen das ist das leben
weitergeht da geht es um existenzen
nicht darunter
da wird mir gesagt sondergenehmigung
einer maske geht es um die existenz der
unternehmer wir müssen uns mehr um den
mittelstand und handwerk kümmern
da sehe ich einfach deutschland vor
allem die bundesregierung dass wir es
nicht aber sie werden das dem wird
gegenüber weiter durchsetzen und im
zweifel ja auch klagen wahrscheinlich
massiv bekommen dagegen
es gibt dabei noch ein zweites phänomen
das man berücksichtigen muss die eine
tatsache die in den studien bestätigt
wird das wenn der impfstoff wirksam ist
also wer geimpft ist wird nicht krank
die zweite frage die noch nicht geklärt
ist dass merz weitertragen körper es
vielleicht weiter trägt das heißt bevor
wir nicht auch sicher sind dass das so
genannte sterile immunität vermittelt
wird von dem impfstoff und man eben auch
als geimpfter niemand anderen mehr
anstecken kann gibt es sowieso noch also
weiter flader gründe für zb das wird
auch der entscheidende punkt sein wenn
sie jetzt sagen ganz früh in den ersten
tagen dieses jahres würden begonnen
werden können zu impfen dann kommt die
große welle irgendwann im frühjahr haben
sie gesagt bis dann wirklich in der
breite geimpft werden kann und wann wird
ihrer meinung nach der punkt sein wo wir
wo es wieder volle stadien geben wird wo
wieder geimpfte und vielleicht dann auch
irgendwann nicht geimpfte wieder in
konzerten zusammen kommen wann rechnen
sie damit
also es kann jetzt seriös wirklich
leider keiner sagen weil das hängt davon
ab wie viele impfstoffe jetzt eigentlich
zugelassen werden also wir haben jetzt
relativ grünes licht richtung dem stoff
von biontech und dem von moderner
weitere astrazeneca wird viel diskutiert
ob die jetzt länger brauchen oder nicht
und dann gibt es weitere firmen die auch
in vorbereitung eines impfstoffs sind
wenn die alle erfolgreich zugelassen
werden und alle in etwa gleich gut sind
dann haben wir natürlich weil alle
irgendwo produktionskapazitäten haben
irgendwann sehr viel impfstoff werden
aber von den kandidaten was heute keiner
weiß es noch zwei oder drei komplett
scheitern also nicht zur verfügung
stehen oder fünfzehn prozent schlechter
sind als er anderen dass sie sagen den
nehme ich das sind die unklaren
variablen oder dann sind wir derzeit
plant grundlegender gehen sie davon aus
dass 20 21 überhaupt noch das jahr sein
wird mit vollen stadien mit konzerten
also ich glaube dass die pandemie 20 21
schrittweise ihren strecken verliert
aber wie weit wir wirklich kommen kann
keiner sagen aber ich glaube dass eben
mit dem frühjahr und dem durch impfen
gerade auch der bilderrahmen gruppen wir
an dem dem was uns am meisten beschwert
nämlich die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems die schweren fälle
und den modus zeit schon sehr sehr weit
kommen können und deshalb bin ich auch
überzeugt dass wir dann wenn der sommer
uns geholfen hat durch die zeit zu
kommen das dann wäre im herbst nicht
mehr mit solchen beschränkungen arbeiten
müssen wie wir das jetzt erleben da bin
ich sehr zuversichtlich finden sie dass
es ist eine hoffnung das kann keiner
versprechen sie das herr hück
unanständig wenn man sich in dieser
phase in dieser pandemie nicht impfen
lässt
ich würde die unanständig sagen ich bin
für sind ein ganz klarer gibt es gar
keine diskussion ich habe übersetzung
jugendliche
eine stiftung 300 also gar wie einfach
eine verantwortung gegenüber
ich werde jedem empfehlen sich zu impfen
ich unanständig
ich würde eher die leute überzeugen
wieder was als auch gemacht haben die
leute zu überzeugen leute wie auch unser
freies leben wieder zurückhaben wollen
wenn wir wollen dass der mittelstand
wieder stark wird dann müssen wir etwas
tun und das ist in villach und bin ich
schon überzeugt aber mehr bauen damit
ihnen sagen sie müssen dafür einfach mal
einstellen dass mehr 20 21 wieder ein
normales leben führen
bekommen sie auch bekommt die politiker
feiern wir zu oft grund wir haben keine
ostern und wir lassen uns auf den punkt
kommen die menschen wollen hören dass
wir 20 21 doch unser allerdings normale
versprechen weil im zweifel muss das
versprechen zurückholen so habe ich sie
verstanden aber lassen sie uns noch mal
ganz kurz beim beim impfen bleiben also
sie sagen nicht unanständig aber lasst
uns die leute überzeugen dass die impfen
gehen genauso sagte rösler
wir brauchen wie ist das mit medizinern
mit ärzten mit pflegepersonal ist das
verantwortungslos wenn die sich nicht
impfen lassen
erst mal grundsätzlich ist es so dass
ich auch finde man muss über das impfen
überzeugen das haben wir auch gesagt es
gibt keine impfpflicht
und ich hoffe das ist sehr sehr viele
menschen wahrnehmen und ich bin sehr
überzeugt im gesundheitswesen wo die
ansteckungsrisiken sehr sehr real sind
da wird die impfquote ohnehin hoch sein
sie wird auch bei den älteren sehr hoch
sein und bei den jüngeren die sozusagen
weniger furcht vor krone haben da ist
sie vielleicht niedriger
sie sind aber auch wichtig weil sie eben
für die verbreitung des virus eine große
rolle spielen und deshalb werden wir für
das impfen das ist er aber sollte es für
einzelne berufsgruppen sprich vor allen
dingen der korona freund für
krankenschwestern für ärzte solle es
nicht geben nein wir haben sehr deutlich
gesagt eine impfpflicht soll es nicht
geben
und angesichts der tatsache dass wir
jetzt auch sehen
der impfstoff wird neu zugelassen wir
sehen es gibt zb auch tierische reserve
gesehen man katzen weil wenn es also so
was wie bei masern dass man ein
langjährig bekannten impfstoff hat wo
das ziel der whu ist wirklich eine
komplette krankheit wieder auszurotten
das eine völlig andere lage deshalb war
ich sehr für die impfpflicht bei den
masern und kann mir eine impfpflicht bei
krone nicht verstanden hat es ist
ausgerechnet diese großen fragen wie
gesagt das sehen wir auch an unseren
zuschauern die haben da wirklich zu
hunderten auch zum impfen fragen
gestellt gerade diese frage wird zum
beispiel outgesourced wird an den
deutschen ethikrat im moment
outgesourced sozusagen die haben wir im
moment sozusagen das wording gegeben der
bundesregierung wird die bundesregierung
sagt im moment ja ja das passt schon so
mit dem ethikrat sollten diese große
fragen nicht im bundestag breit
diskutiert werden na klar
und ich erwarte dass man gutes ahnen
lassen auch machen nicht ist oder wir
müssen die politiker die gelegt worden
sind und in den bürgerinnen und bürger
die müssen mich gehen diskutieren sie
müssen wieder von berlin zurück in den
städten ingenieure und mit den menschen
diskutieren das fähig und sage einfach
ist wer von oben herab von der kanzel
hier das ist nicht demokratisch
landsberg am lech gemüse wie vertreter
ist von jetzt an gezielt und sie müssen
zum voll bewusst mit dem volk wegen und
nicht mit söder sondern mit dem volk
dann bin ich überzeugt dann kommen wir
schnell nach kurths lage herr braun das
ist ja dann die entscheidende frage also
kommt dass in dem bundestag wie man mit
mehr freiheit für geimpfte zum beispiel
umgehen könnte kommt dass in den
bundestag für das da diskutiert bekommt
dass ein gesetzlicher grundlage also
zunächst mal ist es so dass die frage
jetzt dem prioritäten und dazu haben wir
den ethikrat auch die leopoldina und vor
allen dingen die ständige impfkommission
beim robert koch institut die seit
jahrzehnten
die empfehlungen ausspricht alle unsere
kinder wir wahrscheinlich selbst sind
alle geimpft worden nach den
empfehlungen der ständigen
impfkommission das ist ein fachgremium
die da sehr präzise arbeitet wir haben
jetzt die leopoldina hinzugebeten den
ethikrat und ich glaube dass wenn sie
sind sehr ausgewogene empfehlung und das
ganze fußt auch auf einer gesetzlichen
grundlage die gerade erst im deutschen
bundestag beschlossen worden ist also im
neuen bevölkerungsschutz gesetz steht
auch eine passage drin eben diese
priorisierung der impfung beinhaltet und
auf der grundlage arbeitet dann jetzt
die bundesregierung ist total spannend
auch damit beschäftigen sich unsere
zuschauer da kommt die frage von dieter
henze zb aus mainz
jahre alt und seit ca 20 jahren
lungenkrank und somit risikogruppe in
welcher form werde ich erfasst oder
beurteilt und für eine impfung
vorgesehen
total wichtige frage der weiß natürlich
genau der ist risikogruppe einmal wegen
des alters und dann vor allen dingen
wegen seiner vorerkrankung und glaubt
das merkt aber gar niemand merkt niemand
dass der risikogruppe ist wie kommt das
gas wie weiß das gesundheitsamt das also
aufgrund in seinem fall ist das sehr
einfach weil er aufgrund seines alters
schon absolut zur prioritären gruppe
gehört und was vor ort organisiert
werden muss was in der tat schwieriger
es gibt ja auch leute mit einer sehr
schweren vorerkrankungen die relativ
jung sind und für die muss man dann
entsprechendes verfahren entwickeln aber
das gibt es noch nicht nur dass er total
wichtig die frage kam zehnfach also wie
merken sie dass da jemand sitzt zuhause
der risikogruppe es musste sich melden
muss irgendwo anrufen hallo muss er nach
nachweis vorlegen oder wie soll es
laufen er hat dazu bauen jetzt gerade
die die kassenärztliche
bundesvereinigung und module auf um
sozusagen digital die termin anmeldungen
zu machen und dann auf der grundlage der
empfehlung wird es dann heißen welche
altersgruppen welche vorerkrankung des
gruppen werden prioritär geimpft und
dann wird man die möglichkeit haben wenn
man selber zu so einer gruppe gehört
dort anzurufen um bescheid zu sagen und
sich dann einen termin für eine impfung
okay aber da gibt es noch keinen plan zu
das heißt das muss man jetzt erstmal
entwickeln man weiß ungefähr wie im
priorisiert aber man nicht schon ganz
viele pläne also die gesundheitsminister
von bund und ländern arbeiten tag und
nacht brannten und sozusagen die die
konkrete aufforderung an die die
menschen kommt dann wenn jetzt die
ständige impfkommission noch mal gesagt
hat wie genau in kenntnis des konkreten
impfstoffs das außen und so letzte frage
zuschauerfrage kommt von einem den sie
vielleicht erkennen werden
tony marshall und will sie etwas fragen
ein wunderschöner abend herr minister
braun
mein name ist tony marshall ich bin
künstler thomas eine frage an sie das
alleinsein für ältere mitbürger in
unserem land ist ein riesengroßes thema
und ich weiß von was ich spreche denn
ich glaube viele älteren menschen auch
in meinem alter wären in der adventszeit
schon das risiko eingegangen und hätten
sich trotz corona gerne mit ihren enkeln
und urenkeln getroffen und sie herzhaft
in den arm genommen und nun zur frage
was glauben sie
stern nicht mehr menschen an einsamkeit
als an corona das ist ein sehr sehr sehr
ernstes thema deshalb haben wir ja auch
zum beispiel lange darüber diskutiert
wie soll das zu weihnachten sein wollen
wir die empfehlung aussprechen dass man
seine enkel besser nicht sieht bei der
infektionszahlen so hoch sind und ich
glaube nach einem land nach einem jahr
von so viel distanz und wenig treffen
und haben wir uns entschieden dass wir
gesagt haben nein wir wollen eigentlich
genau dass wenigstens zu weihnachten
solche familien begegnungen möglich
werden
und das hat man mir gesagt aber das ist
nicht ohne risiko wenn du angesichts der
hohen zahlen und deshalb haben wir die
empfehlung ausgesprochen dass gerade die
die schulkinder und die berufstätigen
eltern in der woche vor weihnachten so
ein schutz woche einlegen wo sie
wirklich ihr leben noch mal ganz stark
herunterfahren ihre kontakte ganz
deutlich reduzieren damit sie sich
wirklich auch in der vorweihnachtswoche
eigentlich gar nicht angesteckt haben
können
und wenn man sich so auf das
weihnachtsfest vorbereitet dann ist
natürlich auch ein treffen mit den
älteren in der familie etwas was dann
von infektionsrisiko die frage am ende
hält an einsamkeit gestorben als an
corona es war die frage von herrn
marshall egal ob wir das jetzt
statistisch da genau gegeneinander
aufwiegen können aber das ist ein
ernstes thema die korona krise hat
einsam gemacht vor allen dingen bei
alten menschen muss ich eben da bin ich
sogar auffassung dass wir da etwas frei
sein müssten
ich bin wieder bei den doppelmoral den
uni liga man darf auf den bahnhöfen und
hinzu überall lassen leute seien im zug
aber man darf seine oma besuchen
ich hätte versucht zugelassen mit
abstand handlungen mit masken älteren
menschen brauchen enkel und urenkel
es werden ziehe an einsamkeit sterben
und brauchen dann können wir waren was
ihr wollt ihr müsst das frei machen weil
sonst werden wir eine generation der
älteren menschen haben ihre keine keine
lebens schluss mehr haben
das was wir von denen einer ware
begünstigt und anstellen ich würde ihre
menschen uns herr rösler der bayerische
ministerpräsident hat heute sehr
eindringlich nochmal über die korona
toten gesprochen und hat sinngemäß
gesagt es gibt in deutschland irgendwie
nicht genügend emotionalität nicht
genügend empathie für diese corona toten
ist das so ihrer meinung nach ist das so
dass uns die emotionen fehlen und zu oft
die korona toten statistiken statt nur
in statistiken stattfinden
nicht ich würde das nie so negativ sehen
und wenn sie auch sich irgendwie die
solidarität in deutschland ag europaweit
vielleicht dieser weltweit gewesen ist
mit den menschen wo man zu hause
geblieben ist kein aufruf gemacht hat
ich finde das war schon stark
man hat das eben gemacht und gerade
geschwächten in einer gesellschaft die
chronisch kranken die älteren eben zu
schützen und auch die jetzigen maßnahmen
möglich auch noch so streitig sein haben
eben genau das zum ziel
und auch wenn
auf gewisse aufgrund von mancher und
logik die leute vielleicht nicht alles
gut finden und sich auch nicht alles 100
prozent rein halten die große breite
mehrheit tut es doch eben weisen wir
eigene verantwortung wissen und ich
finde gerade gesellschaft bedeutet das
gut hingekriegt zwischen freiheit und
verantwortung die richtige balance zu
finden
also ich finde es nicht so negativ sehen
und das wird auch ungerecht gegenüber
all denen die menschen in deutschland
die wirklich viel in kauf nehmen und es
wurde gerade einfach auf weihnachten wie
viele haben sich jetzt entschieden
unseren freundes bekannten heißt denn
dieses mal
einmal weniger die verwandte zu besuchen
daneben über skype oder war immer in
kontakt zu bleiben eben um seine
verwandten die älteren zu schützen
also da würde ich mal sagen das ist aus
meiner sicht nicht der fall
diese verbrauchen auch wenn das nicht
ganz so gesagt hat für zu viele
deutschland sind viele corona tote zu
oft nur statistik wir müssen uns alle
war mal schütteln wenn wir jeden tag
diese nachricht kriegen heute 450 tote
dass man das nicht einfach nur als zahl
sieht sondern das sind menschen die
vielleicht noch zehn 15 jahre ihres
lebens glücklich hätten verbringen
können hätte es diese krone ansteckung
nicht gegeben auch weil er oft gesagt
wird ja die sind ja meistens älter und
das ist aus meiner sicht überhaupt kein
argument sondern und darüber hinaus
neben den toten auch die schweren
verläufe den wir sehen wo wir vielleicht
auch erst und einiger zeit genau wissen
wie www großbild was da mit
langzeitfolgen zu erwarten ist also das
alles in der summe macht einen
unglaublich großen wert zu sagen wir
wollen die zahlen reduzieren wir wollen
diese toten nicht riskieren wir wollen
auch nicht langzeitfolgen riskieren
sondern wir wollen mit sehr sehr
niedrigen infektionszahlen durch die
pandemie kommen ich bin überzeugt das
wird uns nicht nur gesundheitlich das
kommt uns auch wirtschaftlich und sozial
versteht oder erfolgt an den punkt haben
wir die sendung begonnen was an
verschärfungen möglicherweise noch droht
damit wollen was ganz kurz noch
beschließen vielen dank erhöht vielen
dank herr rösler letzte wort hat der
kanzleramtsminister wals den deutschen
alltag natürlich betrifft das heißt nach
weihnachten kommt die verschärfung wenn
es nach ihnen geht also ich glaube dass
wir weil ein loch da und dieser art auf
dauer nicht funktioniert dass wir
mindestens in den hotspots noch mal
richtig deutliche verschärfungen machen
müssen jede region jedes bundesland auch
jeder landkreis direkt nach war eine
reine dynamik haben die zügig auf die 50
runter geht direkt nach weihnachten also
vor weihnachten verschärfen für die zeit
nach weihnachten wir müssen quasi
erreichen dass wir die zahlen so schnell
wie möglich unter 50 haben und dann im
januar februar märz wenn noch winter ist
die
zahlen niedrig halten bevor uns dann
impfen und frühling hilft dass wir
ohnehin solide lockerung über silvester
das tut mir auch noch kippen wäre heute
bayern selber gehört also es war immer
klar es gibt eigentlich keine lockerung
über silvester silvesterpartys soll es
nicht geben
diese dieser spielraum war gedacht hatte
frau schwesig sehr für gekämpft dass
jemand der schichtarbeit über
weihnachten macht das weihnachtsfest mit
der familien und nachholen kann
aber wenn diese regelung sozusagen zum
einfallstor wird weil weil einige wenige
schichtarbeiter betroffen sind während
millionen andere das zum anlass nehmen
silvester zu feiern dann bin ich sehr
dafür sollte man sehr deutlich machen
ich akzeptiere eine ausnahme für
schichtarbeit aber für alle anderen gilt
die weihnachts besucher bis 27 oder 28
dezember und über silvester gibt es in
diesem jahr möglich keine möglichkeit da
partys zu feiern also weihnachten ist
erst mal dann der letzte moment noch mal
zum ein bisschen ein bisschen
durchschnaufen im rahmen der genannten
regeln und danach kommt noch mal wenn es
nach ihnen geht ein verschärfter locker
und der dann mit kraft die zahlen runter
bringen soll unterdrücken soll im januar
vielen dank für den besuch
kanzleramtsminister helge braun hier am
sonntagabend bei bild vielen dank für es
aushalten ihnen einen schönen rest abend
gute nacht und bis nächsten sonntag
abend
[Musik]